عليك أن ترى كيف تنتشر هذه المرأة
هنا بالطريقة التي
تستخدم بها القمامة بشكل أساسي للقيام بهذه
الأزياء الراقية مثل ارتداء الملابس أو
تقليد كيم كارداشيان برقائق القصدير
أو زينة كاوبوي المزيفة
تحدثت كريستينا فيتزباتريك معها ، إنها
مصممة اختفت  هذه
الملابس التي تصنعها بنفسك والتي تبدو تمامًا مثل
الأزياء الراقية في غضون دقائق في
أكياس القمامة
[موسيقى] تعتبر
أنجليكا هيكس هي أداة الأعمال اليدوية النهائية التي
حصلت على أكثر من 9 ملايين إعجاب
على مقاطع الفيديو الخاصة بها على موقع Tick Tock أثناء قيامها بإعادة إنتاجها
باهظة الثمن ومتقنة
ملابس Oat Couture ذات الأشياء الموجودة حول
منزلها لطالما كان ذهني مختلفًا بعض الشيء
كما أفكر في الأشكال وبعد ذلك
يمكنني تطبيق الأشكال على
الحقيبة اليومية في كيس قمامة
وعقل Hicks الإبداعي ،
تصبح الحقيبة البلاستيكية السوداء لاتكس Kylie Jenner الأسود الصغير
يجب أن يكون الفستان
أو Balenciaga GAO من Naomi Campbell أو
ابتكاري المفضل من Josh vigory هو
مشروع Y حيث يصبح
الأحذية الأحذية التي أضفتها من النوع  إذا كنت تحب
ابنتك لأنها
بعد ذلك ، فإن المفضلة لدي والتي كنت
أفكر فيها مؤخرًا هي تايلور سويفت
في VMAs إذا نظرت إلى الصور التفصيلية ،
فهي مثل
إنشاء مرصع بالجواهر المعقدة الجميلة وهكذا كما
أراه وأنا  أنا مثل يا إلهي هذا هو
إكليل الزينة النحيف الذي هو بالضبط
ما لاحظه المصممون والمشاهير
من حيل هيكس آه أوه حسنًا في
اليوم الآخر في TED Talk ، جعلت
ليدي غاغا تعلق على أن هذا
أمر مذهل.  في فيديو بالما الخاص بي
حيث استخدمت قطعة من شجرة لصنع
قمة وأنا حرفيًا كنت حقًا كما لو كان من
الواضح أنها تشبه
هيك مبدعًا لديها هذه النصيحة
لزي الهالوين في اللحظة الأخيرة وأعتقد أن
ارتداء ملابس كارداشيان
أسهل بكثير  مما قد نعتقد أنني رأيته في
عيد ميلادها في نهاية الأسبوع الماضي ، كانت ترتدي مثل هذا
النوع من الملابس البيضاء الشفافة
مثل الملابس الداخلية ، وكنت في ذهني
مثل هذا يبدو حرفيًا مثل
خيوط العنكبوت وهذا يمكن أن يكون
طريقة رائعة لتكون محبوبًا  e Halloween Kim K
لقد استمتعت للتو بأن كريستينا تشكرك
مباشرةً بعد تلك المقابلة ،
أمسك أنجليكا حرفياً بخيوط عنكبوت الزخرفة
وجعلت المظهر الجنة
بخير ، انتظر ثانية ، انتظر ثانية ، لا
يستغرق الأمر سوى بضع ثوانٍ هنا وهو أمر
جيد.